let f and g be the functions defined by
f of x is equal to one plus x plus e to
the x squared minus two x and g of x
equal x to the fourth minus six point
five x squared plus six x plus 2. let r
and s be the two regions enclosed by the
graphs of f and g shown in the figure
above so here i have the graphs of the
two functions and then close regions r
and s
so the first thing they want us to
figure out is find the sum of the areas
of region r and s
so the sum of those areas you could
think about it we're going to go from x
equals 0 right over here to x equals 2
so we're going to take the integral from
x equals let me write this down area of
r plus s
is equal to let me write let me write
that a little bit neater
so the area
of
r plus s
is going to be equal to
let's see we could take the integral
from x equals zero to x equals to
x equals zero to x equals two and what
are we going to integrate well we're
going to integrate the difference
between the two functions and really the
absolute value of the difference
remember we want the sums we don't want
to have negative area here we want the
sum of the areas of regions r and s and
at some point you have g of x is above f
of x and at other points f of x is above
g of x but if we take the absolute value
it doesn't matter which one we're
subtracting from the other we're just
getting the absolute value of the
difference so let's take the absolute
value of
the absolute value of f of x
minus
minus g of x
dx
so that's going to be the sum of the
areas or we could say this is going to
be the integral from 0
to 2 of the absolute value f of x is
1 plus x plus e to the x squared minus
two x
minus g of x so minus x to the fourth
plus six point five x squared
minus six x minus 2. take the absolute
value
dx now this would be pretty hairy to
solve if we did not have access to a
calculator but lucky for us on this part
of the ap exam we can use a graphing
calculator so let's do that to evaluate
this definite integral here and if
you're wondering why don't i say minus 2
instead of plus 2 remember we're
subtracting we're subtracting g of x
we're finding the difference between
them so let's let's input this function
into my calculator and i'm going to do
the same thing that i did in part one
where i'm just going to define let me
turn it on
all right
so i'm going to actually clear that out
and i'm going to find this whole
expression as y1
so i am going to take the absolute value
so
let me see where the absolute value it's
been a little while since i last used
one of these
so actually maybe some math
math number oh there you go absolute
value
so it's the absolute value of one
plus
x
second e to the
and then we have x squared
minus 2
x
and then close that parentheses and then
you have minus
x
to the fourth power
plus 6.5
times
x squared
minus 6 times x
minus 2 and then we have to close the
parentheses around the absolute value
all right so we've inputted y1 and so
now let's go over here and also evaluate
this definite integral so we go to math
and then we scroll down
to
definite for function integral
so click on that and we're going to use
y once we go to variables we go to the
right to go to y variables it's a
function variable that we just defined
and so we select y1 that's what we just
inputted our variable of integration is
x
and our bounds of integration well we're
going to go from x equals 0 to x equals
2. so we go from 0
to
2.
and then we let the calculator munch on
it a little bit
and
we
get
it's taking some time to
to calculate this still it's still
munching on it
let's see
this is
taking
a good bit of time
there you go all right so it's
approximately 2.00
if you want a little more precise 2.004
so this is approximately 2.004.